[Music]
thank you for attending our talk this
afternoon and I'd like to highlight the
read do have other quote and
contributors but unfortunately they
weren't able to make it today so this
paper presents the intended aims of the
project and how this was achieved and
the visualization work we've done
including creating interactive maps of
the results so the overall aim of the
project is to use the data set produced
by text mining about five thousand and
five hundred medical office of health
reports covering the Greater London area
spanning from 1848 to 1972 as a tool to
explore and interpret the lives and
health of 19th and 20th century
Londoners
this is a collaborative
interdisciplinary project and our aim is
to enhance and demonstrate the
capabilities of innovative text mining
tools we designed to allow the automatic
extraction of information from OCR text
furthermore if the data becomes more
structured they can be readily overlaid
with other information such as maps and
images having multiple layers will
enable us to run various comparisons and
assess if there are any correlations
between smells and diseases as well as
links to their socio-economic identity
of areas of London so text mining tools
and any derived resources are made
available to the wider community by a
github and the project website we have
been working on this project for just
over a year part time and still have
some more work to do
so I'm going to go through what we've
done during our first phase in 2016 so
we successfully data mined over 5,000
and 500 MOH reports and created the data
set of smell related words and produce
the simple map and so far this year we
categorize the smells in the data set
and create the new map which I'm going
to show you later on and we are
currently working on extracting implied
smells and we will be producing a report
on how smells are linked to health and
the socio-economic identity of London
boroughs so I'm going to tell you it's
been more about the MOH report so each
local authority was required to appoint
moh who oversaw the work of a team of
assistive medical officers sanitary
inspectors health visitors and clerks as
they carried out the work necessary to
meet their public health
responsibilities does that happen during
the 19th century so am I to report to
annual reports that hold on issues such
as mortality rates disease outbreaks
sanitation portaging school health and
food inspection including lots of issues
around ice-creams I don't know whether
you guys are aware of them health issues
around ice-cream in the 19th century and
they've been long regarded as an
important source for the 19th and 20th
century history of Public Health and
stem from a reaction to infectious
disease in mid 19th century so you might
wonder why derf London so I work for
Wellcome Trust and we digitized about
you know as I explained the 5,500 London
reports a few years ago and made them
available online in the resource called
London's pulse we've just started
digitizing approximately 70,000 reports
covering the rest of the UK and Ireland
so they will become available through
the Internet Archive and welcome
therefore we thought it would be a great
opportunity to run a pilot project using
these London reports and there are other
reasons for data mining the reports the
close reading of these reports can be
extremely challenging first of all as I
and earlier there are over 5,000 and 500
individual reports and some reports
contain about 150 pages or more so they
present a daunting amount of reading
secondly overall these reports are very
dry and full of very detailed effects
and statistical data so it's not too
riveting reading experience and lastly
although these reports were not
standardized and also were able to
express the diversity of their local
communities and their own personal
interests the majority of the reports
are similar in many respects in terms of
their main contents therefore they're
largely repetitious and read in large
quantities so we conclude that will
benefit from using text mining tools to
extract useful knowledge and to discover
interesting patterns with less human
effort so now I'm going to move on to
why I became interested in smells so
smells are part of how we understand the
world around us Roy Porter the popular
and well-regarded the medical historian
claimed that today's history come to be
authorized although we also know what
the past looked like we don't get a
chance to hear feel or smell the past
medical historians have incorporated
some aspects of sensory history into
their research and explore the past
beliefs the bad smells were closest
causes of disease however there's very
little research carried out covering
this period furthermore the despite the
rise of germ theory in the 1880s
concerns with the disease-causing miasma
meaning smells did not disappear
entirely so during the 19th century the
paranoia surrounding smells associated
with the poor hygiene heightened in many
European cities I think the great think
of 1858 is a great example are you
familiar with a great stink of 1858
anyone okay I thought of everyone in the
UK knew about this
so the image you can see here is a
captain from punch magazine and it was
June 1855 showing how smelly the River
Thames was there was the overwhelming
stench from the River Thames in the
summer of 1858 London came to a
standstill and the possibility of moving
parliament to either Oxford or 10 Albans
was seriously considered to get away
from the River Thames so in my view the
smells contribute to a construction of
places socio-economic identities for
example the greasy smells coming from
fat food restaurants are often
associated with rundown areas about a
year ago I found this article published
in The Guardian in which the phrase the
chicken shop mile Intelli Hamlet's one
in eight children starting primary
school are obese and that doubles to
more than one in four when they leave at
age 11 the borough has the fifth highest
rate of child obesity in London and the
sixth in the country health
professionals believe that the 42
chicken shops for secondary school in
the borough are one of the reasons I
live in Tower Hamlets and I can smell
fried chicken underwear here this
morning researcher John sighs chicken so
and then also according to London's
poverty profile almost half of children
in Tower Hamlets live in poverty and so
that the highest rate in London and town
Hamlet had the second highest
unemployment rate across London in 2014
although the rates Bingham falling since
so there's also a high rate of
overcrowding in Tower Hamlets so all of
this has an effect on the smells of the
borough furthermore it is debatable how
good an order is as a marker of disease
but there is something called olfactory
medicines or flattery meaning and smell
so medics use their sense of smell to
help them diagnose illness moreover
sniffer dogs can be trained to detect
illnesses such as cancer
so I'm going to show you the image we
put briefly so the image here you see on
the left hand side is the survey
questions the MOH set and so the
question the second question here is
that do you receive many complaints of
offensive smells and the next question
was have you ever been able to trace any
connection between offensive smells and
diseases so the MiG talks about in some
towns the medical of this health report
that they've been able to trace a
connection between the effluvia from the
sewer sewer ventilators and disease the
table on the right shows an examination
of death rates from all causes as well
as links to the sewer ventilators so
although inconclusive in this report the
MOH highlight the correlation between
smells and diseases such as diptheria
in particular so these are the snippets
of smells mentioned in DM which reports
and now I'm going to hand over to
Michael heroes who is going to go
through the technical side of things
which you might find them more
interesting okay
Thank You Debra so there are two main
components to the project the bit that I
worked on was the data mining in Python
3 and there's also the second component
which is the visualization using
javascript and leaflet to share the data
between two components we use SQL lights
the reason for choosing SQL light DB is
easy to use and quite simple so the data
mining itself was quite quick to perform
initially it was taking around 15
minutes on an everyday laptop I took
advantage of using multi processing in
Python via current and concurrent
futures and this reduced the time it's
about five minutes so how do we
determine that a sentence in the report
is smell related so we literally split
up the reports in two sentences and the
way we did that was by using nop.k in
ldk tokenization so once we had the
sentences in the report we're then able
to identify the sentences that contain
Smouse we could dense further categorize
the smell related sentences
so for example we look at a sentence and
if the sentence contained rubbish or
sewer we could then identify this as a
waste related smell we're then able to
take those sentences and display them
via leaflets on a map which Deb will
demonstrate shortly to break down the
kinds of smells in the different
boroughs that we're seeing over London
so there's definitely more advanced ways
we could analyze the the smell related
words via n LT k NLT Kay's not the most
user-friendly tool now the reason we
want to do that is to gain more advanced
contextual understanding of the
sentences and also to reduce false
positives that we're seeing in the data
sets just wanted to mention that this is
an open source project and we're happy
to have more involvement in the project
so if you have interest in perhaps
visualization or NLP kay please speak to
us after the talk and we've been more
than happy for people to involved now
going to hand you back to Deborah to
display the maps itself
so and this is the the first map that we
created so during the first phase we
created this smelly map based on the
number of smells it's to visualize and
the first set of results we realities
and the from the list of the existing
London local authorities for the MOH
report to be compiled the geographic
coordinates of present-day equivalents
were extracted using an API and
therefore the places that did not exist
in the API we manually added the
geographic coordinates from Wikipedia so
we couldn't then I spoke to a lots of
some GIS specialists and we do a lot of
mapping and we weren't able to get them
enough help on the 19th century
coordinates or so if you have an access
to that kind of data please let us know
you're still looking and so let me just
and explain this map maybe we can
display okay
so on the map each of the points marks
the number of smells occurring at the
centroid of each of the locations we
group the number of smells in two sets
of ten to avoid having giant points on
the map for the places where there's
there are almost hundred smells recorded
and then the maps grows through the
years as well and I'm going to we are
going to show you the second map that we
just created so and this is the second
map that we've created using an
JavaScript library called the leaflet
DOJ's and so we've got this pie chart
here you can click on and then pop-ups
will tell you which report it is and the
number of smells they recorded within
each report and then on the right hand
side you will see more detailed
information so you get some type of
smells and also that we are linking it
to the actual reports when you click on
it it will open will take you to the
actual report so if you want to
investigate further UK I think the
Internet is really slow
and also that we've oh yeah so when
there's a no pie chart you can still
click on one of the borrows and then if
you want to look whether there were any
smells reported through time then you
can use the time slider to go through so
maybe that bar wasn't that smelly in the
past and then also that you can filter
it so if you are just interested in
sewer you can click on sort yeah
[Music]
now what
I think the Internet is quite slow not
filtering if it worked ok so yeah so
that's how tens related them smell that
I just filtered and then what you can do
is if you're interested in them seeing
which borrow to them the temporal Thames
River related smells reported so yeah so
this is a map that we've just finished
the creating about a month ago and that
worked actually and then on our website
we also put some the list of some
current London local authorities we've
used and there are lots of so the full
researchers that understanding
historical local authorities is quite a
complex and process so there's a really
brilliant website called and I think
it's called the vision US and Britain
through time so we are hoping to get an
API to to link to this website / Bora
and then we also created them smelly pie
charts using plotly so it was really
easy and they are visualizing and the
smells we extracted and the next is so
this is a list of things we are
currently working on and then one thing
that we are really keen to do is
extracting them 19th century plate names
and we have to rely on this part of the
project by another project called a
mayors of London it's led by a group of
academics and we are hoping to to get
some 19th century gazetteer of place
names and then what we are planning to
do is the ones we are able to extract
the place names with a smell related
work and Daniele and his team from
Cambridge University will make our
datasets available on their smelly maps
so this is a team of people from the
Cambridge University extracted 21st
century smells and they mapped it and I
can just show you so yeah this is their
smelly map and if you just click on one
of the streets in London it will tell
you the breakdown of smells they
extracted streets name called long court
and then you can see that 43.8% was a
ways to relate your smells so we are
also building on ontology so they this
team has built an ontology of them
smells of 21st century and we are trying
to adopt their ontology to build ours
but so far because of the way people
perceive the smells and reported smells
in the 19th century we weren't able to
use their ontology so we are building
our own and based on day ontology so
that when we want to combine our data
set with theirs then we can work more
easily and so hopefully in the next year
or so that people should be able to
search smells of their Street from 19th
century to present day so thank you for
listening and if you have any questions
yes
[Applause]
the data extraction of the words you're
actually searching it seems to me you've
got something like rubbish how do you
know that this is a complaint about the
smell of the rubbish as opposed to
rubbish blocking the territory so we
used word nap from nop.k to work out all
the synonyms for the word smell so you'd
have words like smells stench flew Liam
and then we go through the report and
look for all sentences that contain
those words so therefore we're making
assumption that that sentence refers to
the smell of something and then we would
then look at the contents of that
sentence and then look at if it contains
keywords and then again there's another
assumption being made that if you've got
the word safe smell and sewage in the
sentence we're making the jump that
that's a smell related to search and
also be one just looking for negative
smells so we were also looking for good
smells but people tend to complain about
that now I'm not really you know
lovely country sizing us and also to
being in London I think probably that
was difficult and then you need to
remember this is and public health
related to the reports that medical I
mean medical professionals compiled for
the public and public health
responsibilities so yeah I was looking
for more kind of medical related because
they affected people's health that's why
I find a lot of smell complaints
yeah
so the question was whether the and the
words to describe smells in the
nineteenth century have been consistent
or fluctuate within the century so
within the 19th century it doesn't
really fluctuate and I think based on my
research they inherited lots of them the
adjectives that describe smells from the
18th century so I can see the
correlation but it was very different to
how we describe smells today so quite
often they talk about offensive traits
I don't know whether you've heard of
offensive trade so it's like a tannery
was some prime example in London and so
this report all contained a list of
offensive trading within each forum but
again that we wouldn't call that
offensive trade initiative in that we
don't have tanneries in London and then
bakeries the bake houses worth a lot
it's prevalent in in London and so
within the 19th century try to your
question and it's consistent but our
challenge is to understand the 19th
century kind of kind of medical
professionals way of describing these
smells the affected people's health yeah
ok any other questions
my last a real time exactly that
semester so they so the question was
that whether we've thought about using
Twitter data to extract smells so our
collaborator from Cambridge University
that's what they've done they primarily
use the Twitter feed so they extracted
social media data to map the smelly maps
of 21st century what we are hoping is as
I stand up to just combine our datasets
image that you are able to to look at
how smelly your street was from 1858
till you know present day okay
yeah so that some planets also because
I'm a medical historian so what I'm
interested in looking at some kind of
poverty and the kind of environment and
how they're affected people's health so
we are planning to overlay and to begin
with and childbirth poverty map so and
then we had to the people are trying to
figure out whether there's any and there
are any correlations between people's
and health and welfare cell so I've done
that for the 21st century so I've got
some data from maybe 2010 or 2009 from
sensors so I've usually flipped just a
map and it's a living London living wage
and deaf like mortality rates at birth
and child poverty just to see how it
looks on the map so yeah but we just I I
don't have access to the 19th century
sense of data they haven't been
digitized so again there are lots of
challenges because because of the period
we are covering
so the question was after post 19th with
in 1956 whether there have been any
changes in terms of smells we extracted
so we hadn't really done a lot of data
analysis yet because we are still we
were still working on mapping and
getting the and the tools ready and but
the one thing that I didn't point out
was that this data that the reports are
not complete but as complete as it can
be and during war period for instance
there are lots of missing reports and
maybe during the interwar period as well
that time they published very very thin
and reports covering maybe 10 years so
things like that we looked into
normalizing the data to have a better
representation as well in the future so
you're hopefully in the next few months
we we can do some more analytical work
to see any changes in patterns that we
set out to look for
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
you